[Music]
let's play a game
just me and you any of this mean
anything
to you
you're becoming quiet celebrity
[Music]
[Applause]
why is he writing to you
if you are justice
please do not lie
what is the price for your blind
[Music]
the hell are you supposed to be
vengeance
oh this guy's crazy
[Music]
you're part of this too
how am i part of this
you'll see
[Music]
welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my new batman trailer
video hopefully you've had a chance to
watch the trailer a billion times like
everyone else
since it's been released there are so
many more easter eggs that have been
found
in the background of the footage so
we'll break it all down starting with
court of owls but if you're new to the
channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos we're doing a new amazon giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your favorite
easter egg from the trailer on the video
so we'll just number these as we go
along just to stay organized but just
starting with the greeting card because
there are actually way more easter eggs
going on in this scene than were found
when the trailer first
dropped this past weekend so obviously
there's an owl on the cover it's
halloween themed so yes the reference is
to the court of owls eventually showing
up in the live-action batman movies for
the first time
there's a lot of untapped potential
there for this new version of gotham
city
there's even the new batman gotham
knights video game with the court of
owls being the main villains of that so
they're just showing up a lot more in
pop culture right now
and of course the halloween theme
because of batman the long halloween
story which i've talked about before
partially inspires some of the story of
the film but there's a lot of different
movies that inspire the batman film
the actual riddle on the greeting card
that the riddler leaves says what does a
liar do
when dead the answer to that is that he
lies still
because he's dead he can't move so
obviously that's a reference to the
victim here that he's duct taped up
but the text on the cover of the
greeting card reads from your secret
friend
that's also a huge easter egg for the
zodiac killer for any of you true crime
fans
so back in 1970 the zodiac killer left a
halloween
greeting card note for one of his crime
scenes in the police that looked exactly
like this
with his own version of a riddle in the
police sketch of him
at the time made him look exactly like
the riddler does
with his head covered in glasses on top
of his mask
creepy as hell but matt reeves said in
particular that the aesthetic of the
batman movie was based on gritty 1970s
cop shows in movies like chinatown
think about how the movie chinatown
ended too forget it batman it's
chinatown
that also kind of makes you wonder if
the batman movie will have a similar
not so happy ending so i won't spoil the
ending of chinatown if you haven't seen
it it's a great film so be sure to go
and watch it at some point
but a lot of you will notice that that's
also the same aesthetic as
the joker movie with joaquin phoenix
even though todd phillips claimed that
last year
that there were no plans to cross over
joaquin phoenix's joker with robert
pattinson's batman
it would be badass but the timeline for
that doesn't quite work out because
joaquin phoenix's joker would have to be
in his 60s by the events of the batman
movie
if you look at this lincoln navigator in
this scene of the movie this looks like
it's from the last 10 years
so the movie actually seems like it's
taking place at least in the early 2010s
relatively close to present day the
riddler himself
also resembles the earth 1 version of
the riddler much more stripped down much
more realistic
if you didn't read any of the earth 1
batman comic books that was a version of
batman in his rogues gallery at gotham
city that were much more like the year
one
or even year zero versions of the
characters everyone was running around
in much more realistic costumes no one
had become the fully realized comic book
versions of their characters yet
there was also an army veteran on
twitter recently that noticed that the
riddler's entire costume
in the trailer is army surplus gear that
anybody could go out and buy right now
it's kind of the same situation for some
of batman's gear too like look at his
boots
those look like normal thick boots that
anybody could go by on the street
matt reeves said that batman is in this
constant state of evolving his suit and
his methods because he's only in his
second year of wearing the cape and cow
the gotham news outlets have only been
reporting on him recently and some
people still kind of think of him as a
myth
and the other regular people of gotham
city are afraid of him because he's kind
of like this bat-themed baba yaga
coming into the night just to beat the
crap out of people so he hasn't become
the full symbol of hope for gotham that
he will eventually become over the
course of this new batman trilogy
there were a lot of you that were also
asking about hush in this riddler scene
here just because he's using so much
duct tape in his costume
seems similar to something that hush
would wear as far as i know hush is not
a character in this movie but he does
employ some similar tactics as the
riddler is using here
and during the batman hush comic book
careful for spoilers for that if you
haven't read it yet
so during that story you find out that
the riddler had actually been
manipulating hush the whole time
orchestrating events against batman
after having learned his secret identity
as bruce wayne
hush was another storyline that also
involved all of batman's biggest
villains just like the long halloween
a little while after the trailer was
released we also got confirmation on
colin farrell's version of the penguin
he's this guy here there was a lot of
questions about what was going on with
him in the trailer
he's unrecognizable just because of the
makeup job and extreme prosthetics
he's also the same character in this
scene here during the batmobile chase
yelling this guy is crazy when batman's
coming after him
colin farrell is a fantastic actor so i
can't wait to see what he does
with this version of the character but
the other major chord of owls easter egg
that someone spotted recently was this
reference when batman is using his
grappling hook in the stairwell to clear
this giant group of thugs that are
chasing him through the building
as he's flying up the camera rotates
around at all these people chasing him
you notice one of them is wearing a very
visible owl
mask so the current theory right now is
that that person is just meant to be
another reference to the court of al's
not an actual member of the court
himself like he's not a talent he's not
part of the shadow government he's not
some secret rich person
chasing batman around with his group of
thugs and just like other big batman
villains like the joker the court of
owls won't actually show up
for real in this first new batman movie
they're just planting the references and
seeds for them to eventually show up
later
the current report on the version of the
joker from matt reeves batman movies
multiple movies mind you is that he
won't show up in this first one
but somewhere in the sequels some people
think he's going to show up in the
second film some people think he's going
to show up in the third film
it's too soon to tell but it sounds like
they're introducing a lot of villains
in this first movie and then laying the
groundwork with easter eggs to introduce
even more in the next movie just
creating the universe for robert
pattinson's batman
and right now the only way i think that
matt reeves batman is going to wind up
crossing over with other dc movies like
the justice league character movies
will be through the flash in the
multiverse as far as matt reeves has
said there's not any big plans for that
right now but that could always change
in the future
i just did a big video on the flash
teaser trailer that they released at the
flash movie panel and there was all this
talk about them connecting
all these different dc movies from the
past 30 years
so if you watch the dc tv crisis on
infinite earth's they sort of tried to
connect
a bunch of different tv shows with some
of the movies including the justice
league movie
it sounds like the flash movie will also
do a version of that
for a bunch of other dc movies too so
that's how you explain michael keaton's
batman being on a separate earth from
say like val kilmer's batman and even
george clooney's batman
no joke they did include footage of
clooney and val kilmer's batman during
the big multiverse
montage in the flash movie panel that
doesn't mean that they're going to show
up during the flash movie but they might
make references to quote-unquote
other versions of batman out there
somewhere in the multiverse and that
would include robert pattinson's batman
for now the version of batman that's
going to be crossing over with a bunch
of other dc movies in the future will be
michael keaton's batman and he'll be
coming from the 1989 tim
burton batman movie universe the current
talk is that it'll also be doing a live
action batman beyond movie at some point
with a version of terry mcginnis
there were a lot of you that watched the
batman trailer here and felt like
aesthetically
it felt kind of like a batman beyond
trailer because the logo looks a little
bit like the batman beyond logo the way
it comes in
and robert pattinson's batman looks a
little bit like terry mcginnis or even a
version of nightwing for that matter
if you're looking for a reading list of
the batman comics that inspired the
batman movie obviously i've talked about
batman the long halloween but there's
also batman year one and matt reeves
specifically called out darwin
cook's batman ego as a way to sort of
show batman's duality with bruce wayne
just because it's gonna be much more of
a character-based movie than previous
batman movies
you also probably heard about matt
reeves doing a batman movie spin-off tv
show for hbo so the batman hbo series is
actually going to be set during the
events of batman year one
it'll follow the gotham city police
department and sort of set up the events
of the batman movie i don't know how
many seasons it's going to run
or who all the main characters are going
to be there's a very bullock like
character that they describe when
talking about the main character
but when we find out more about that
series and how batman figures into it
because it is batman year one i'll do
more videos about it
and obviously i will do episode videos
for it when it releases
so everyone just let me know in the
comments all the other easter eggs that
you've spotted
since watching the batman trailer a
billion more times
there were a bunch of video game
trailers that dc dropped so i'll try to
do videos for those two
in the next day or two there's a bunch
of other stuff coming up but leave all
your requests in the comments below i
will do more batman videos as we get
more details about the movie
keep in mind that all the trailer
footage in this trailer here is only
taken from about
25 of the movie so you have to imagine
what it's going to look like when they
finish filming the entire movie it'll be
crazy
while you wait for everything click here
to watch the trailer a billion more
times and click here for the flash movie
teaser trailer and all the other
trailers from dc
fandom thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe
i'll see you guys tonight